i could go back to the lobby too
i don't want to like break the site
uh let's play
let's play
ah
it's funny because people are trying to
get games and then
oh misha
misha is rated 2401 okay
let's try and farm my opponent
is this lightning no this is standard
okay
oh
this is scary
oh this opening i saw this opening
somewhere
i think this is like a professional
opening
i'm playing a very strong player
i think
don't hurt me
oh
oh fancy
uh-oh
i feel like i'm about to get smashed
i don't know why i played
b5 so much regrets
don't
okay i'm in trouble now
and there's no stalemate in this game
that's my one hope
yeah oh no my king
joe
oh dev said this misha person is best
okay let's get revenge
it doesn't matter if you're light or
black because there's no turns
what is this opening let's play a zooker
tour kali
a part of this was just trying to remain
solid and not lose material
oh that was not a good move
wow oh
ah why why is everything cooling down
i played bishop a8
oh no
oh
oh oh
it's not going to work
oh no
oh i dodged the thing but
got hit by the other thing oh no my
queen
okay i resign
oh
that's tough
rematch
wait i want to do lightning though
okay last standard game and then i'll
switch to lightning
okay we're doing a closed sicilian
i will give 20 subs if you can beat
misha even once oh okay
challenge accepted
okay no hanging pieces this time
infinity attempts
oh
take this take this
hmm
i don't know why i'm doing this
i feel like i'm playing without a
strategy
oh
what just happened
wait i'm
the king's mated no
almost
the king still made it
opponent did something
wait
no
don't
my hope and dreams
is there ambassador in this game no
there is
oh i thought i was winning and then all
my pieces vanished i resigned
rematch okay
i i felt like maybe there's i don't know
if i had any hope though
okay
ambassador only
oh interesting
oh
ah
i thought the bishop was going to land
on f3
oh that was a bad move unless i can do
this
wait what oh no
wait what did my rook do
oh
no
the cooldown period is not enough
no
oh
i felt closer
ah
oh
this should be fine
oh wait what
what just happened
uh-oh
oops here goes my queen
no i resign i i lost too many pieces
that was uh
that was a rough opening
[Music]
am i gonna get adopted what's our
lifetime score minus five
could be worse
hippo time
don't mess with my hippo
i'm doing the same thing you're doing
[Music]
draw
are we gonna be at a standstill
we might be
interesting
ah
iraq can take the king but the king will
just dodge
[Applause]
okay i feel like i have hope here
uh oh don't take my queen okay
no
just made it to 2005 oh no
checkers
oh congratulations
oh
why why is opponent have so many pawns
oh no no no no no no no
i resigned
and this opponent's so good
i thought i had a little bit of hope
that game i have to avoid the
do i get to adopt you sure we'll play
four more
hopefully i can avoid adoption though
i mean i'm motivated by this like bounty
of gifted subs
but it's gonna be tough
okay i don't mind the trades
this feels like real chess but it's not
real chess
that seems like a solid position still
i just have to hold my ground
ah tricky tricky
okay
interesting
interesting
wait i'm winning now right
hopefully
no
wait what did i do
was i winning for a moment there
no
all my pieces went away
i think i was winning i'm not sure
though
is it stalemate yet
yeah there's no such thing as check in
this game it's all about taking the king
uh what to do
okay ready
i feel like i had major chances that
game
opponent got complacent
um sure we'll go for the setup again
[Music]
wait wait wait okay
oh no they dodged
ah it's all falling apart
or is it
yeah
be tricky on the king side
i have to go for the all-out attack
no wait how did that happen
okay i resign
i minus seven oh i turned orange
i don't know what that means
and this is so stressful
i should take that
oops
i like cancel a pre-move
maybe that did it
oh no
[Music]
oh
does that work i don't know if that
works though
oh no my keyboard
i'm down the rook
i'm down the rook
oops
oh no my queen
resign
oh it's so unfortunate okay let's play
london
actually what do i play
center control
center control
so we got some pawn tension
to reinforce the center
wow
i have a bad feeling about this
no
wait why is my queen there
why is my work there
oh it's so tough
okay rematch
oh i've already been adopted okay final
game
no mercy now
oh no i already blundered
or did it
wow
[Music]
no
everything's falling
if you take a piece and
ah
yeah pieces are
vanishing
okay
oh
any hope
okay resign gg
[Music]